okay I'm going to give you a quick tour
of Wolfram documentation and show you
some of the things that are new at
eleven point three and along the way
I'll give you some tips on how to use
documentation effectively so the
documentation is available from the help
menu if you click Wolfram documentation
that brings up this route documentation
page and this documents all of the
functions that are available in
Mathematica 5,000 plus functions and
they're grouped according to functional
areas like graphs and networks images
knowledge representation and so forth so
if we go into one of these categories
like sound for example you'll see
several subcategories let's open up
sound generation and this lists the
cluster of functions which have to do
with sound the sonification and let's
open up one of those play one of the new
things are these details thumbnails in
the past the details section was simply
closed now these thumbnails give you
some idea of what's in there if you
click this you can see the content some
people are not aware that you can
evaluate expressions directly on the
documentation so for example I'll
evaluate this input yeah play that and
that since you can evaluate directly in
the in the documentation you can go in
here and play around with it and see how
things work so let's increase the
frequency here for example you can get a
feeling for how the documentation or how
the functions and wolfram mathematica
work and you can do whatever you want on
a documentation page if you go back and
revisit that page you get a fresh page
it's all cleaned up so you'd have to
worry about messing up your
documentation by trying things out I
don't actually very often go through the
root page what I'm more often do is
use the user assistance functionality so
for example if I type in here manipulate
you'll see that I get this pop-up and
you can go immediately to the
documentation for an manipulate by
clicking on the information icon or what
I do even more often is as soon as I
type a opening bracket you'll see this
Chevron here and if you click on that it
will show you all of the different ways
of giving arguments to manipulate and I
use this often because with five
thousand-plus functions is often
difficult to remember what the order of
arguments is and what all the various
argument combinations are and in fact
you can just click one of these options
and you'll get a template that you can
quickly type in code and use tab to tab
to the next placeholder and there you've
got to manipulate very quickly so let me
show you one of the new features of
eleven point three in the documentation
and those are workflows so let's go back
to the root documentation page these
colored tiles up here document functions
and the Wolfram language and the gray
tiles at the bottom document workflows
workflows are units of work how to get
something done they may use functions as
well as interface elements other pieces
of software command line whatever you
need to get some unit of work done so
like the function documentation the
workflows are divided into functional
categories using the Wolfram language
working with data and so forth let's
look at working with graphics images and
sounds these are typical kinds of
workflows how to import an image into a
notebook how to customize charts how to
put graphics in a grid and so on that's
like a particular workflow crop 2d
images
so each workflow is organized in steps
which are numbered so here it's select
the crop tool by clicking on an image
drag out a cropping rectangle adjust a
cropping rectangle if necessary crop the
image and so forth so you can open this
in a separate window or sidebar have it
laying on the desktop like a like a
recipe book like a cookbook and just
follow along the workflow as you're
trying to get something done and you'll
see that we have this new diagrammatic
style of documentation that shows you
the steps how to use the interface
elements and so forth there may be more
than one way of doing something in that
case we have these alternative sections
which are indicated by the ellipses so
there's the interactive way to crop
images as well as several programmatic
ways you might like to crop to remove at
a uniform border crop to a given size
crop trimming a given amount and so
forth in addition to that we have these
platform icons at the top I'm currently
on the desktop this shows how to do
these things on the desktop there are
sometimes differences between the
desktop or cloud or mobile and in that
case if you go to these other tabs it
will show you documentation specific to
those platforms all of our documentation
is online as well as in the desktop and
you can get at it here reference well
from com so it looks pretty much like it
does on the desktop let's take a look at
geometry
ball for example okay you'll notice if
you hover over an input in this
documentation it will show you a
clipboard icon and all you need to do is
click and it automatically copies that
input to the clipboard and then you can
go back to your desktop application
paste and immediately execute that
expression so that makes it very
convenient to use the online
documentation in combination with a
desktop or the cloud so that's what's
new in 11.3 and Wolfram documentation
thank you for your attention